we're about to embark on a new chapter
in this course where I want to tell you
about similarities craft regularity
lemma samurai t-square regularity lemma
is a very powerful tool in modern graph
theory developed back in the 70s today I
want to show you the statement and a
proof of the scraf regularity lemma and
next time we'll see how to apply the
lemma for graph theoretic applications
and we'll also use it to give a proof of
Ross theorem the idea of some Reddy's
regularity lemma is that if you are
given a very large graph and it's a 30
robust theorem so any large tense crap
and here dents means let's say positive
edge density then it is possible to
partition the vertex set of this graph G
into a bounded number of pieces
so that G looks random like between most
pairs of parts so for instance I might
produce for you a partition of the
vertex set into some number of parts
I'll draw five here and so you give me a
graph G I managed to produce for you
this vertex partition so that if I look
at between a typical pair of parts you
see here maybe the edge density is close
to 0.2 but otherwise the bipartite graph
looks like a random graph in some
precise sense I will describe in a bit
and if you look at what the graph looks
like between another pair of parts maybe
now it's a different edge density maybe
it's around 0.4 and again looks like a
random graph with that density
so in some sense similarities regularity
lemma is a universal structural
description that allows you to
approximate a graph by a bounded amount
of information so that's informally the
idea and you can already sense that this
can be a very powerful tool it doesn't
matter what graph you input you apply
this lemma and you get a approximate
structural or as later on we'll see it's
also in some sense an analytic
description of the graph so the first
part of today's lecture
we'll develop just a statement of the
struggle every lemma show you what
exactly do I mean by random like or
first let me give some definitions I
denote by the letter e if I input a pair
of vertex s x and y here I might later
on drop the subscript G if it's clear
that I'm always talking about some graph
G so this is basically the number of
edges between x and y and I say
basically because even though I will
draw and depict everything as if x and y
are disjoint sets and that's the easiest
case to think about I'm also going to
allow X or Y to overlap and also allow x
and y to be the same set in which case
you should read the definition still
what this means but it's fine to think
of it as the stone set so you're looking
at a bipartite graph between x and y
we're also going to look at the edge
density between x and y and this is
simply the number of edges divided by
the product of the sizes of the sets so
what fraction of the possible pairs are
actual edges so from now on I'll refer
to this quantity as edge density okay so
now here's the definition of what random
like means for the purpose of
similarities regularity lemma so define
a notion of an epsilon regular pair to
be as follows so throughout and later on
our or might even saying this G will be
some graph
and we're going to be looking at subsets
of vertices of G and we say that this
pair of subset of vertices is epsilon
regular again in Jeep and later on our
even drop saying in G if it's clear
which graph were working with so we say
X and y is epsilon regular if for all
subsets a of X all be subsets of Y that
are not too small so each at least an
epsilon proportion of the sets that they
live in we find that the edge density
between a and B differs from the edge
density between x and y by no more than
epsilon let me draw you a picture
I have sets a and B so I've set x and y
in my graph G and I want to say that the
edges between x and y are epsilon
regular random like if the following
holds that whenever I pick a subset a in
the left set and a subset B of the right
set the edge density between a and B
it's approximately the same as the
overall an edge density between x and y
so in particular this bipartite graph
for instance it's not really dancing one
part and really sparse in another part
somehow the edges are evenly distributed
in this precise manner so that's the
definition of epsilon regular it's
question
okay the questions here why we're using
the same epsilon here here and there and
that's a great question so that's mostly
out of convenience so you could use
different parameters and they do play
somewhat different roles but at the end
will generally be looking at one type of
epsilon so we just make our life easier
so you could extend the definition by
having an epsilon comma 8 huh if you
like but it will not be necessary for us
and mostly for simplification any more
questions all right
now if you have a pair X Y that is not
epsilon regular I just want to introduce
a piece of terminology so you can read
from the definition what it means to be
not Epsilon regular and sometimes I will
say epsilon
regular but to be precise I'll stick
with not epsilon regular then we can
exhibit this a and B that witnesses that
you regularity so if X Y it's not
epsilon regular then pair irregularity
is say it's witnessed by some pair a in
X and B Y satisfying or basically you
read the definition and such that the
density between a and B differs quite a
bit from the density between x and y so
when I say to exhibit a witness
irregularity that's what I mean now
there's a bit of an unfortunate
nomenclature in graph theory where
previously we said D regular graphs to
mean that every word
the greedy and now we say epsilon
regular to mean this sorry about that
these are both standard so usually from
contacts is clear which one is meant
okay so this is what I means for a
single pair of vertex s to be epsilon
regular but now I give you a graph and I
give you a partition of the vertex set
all right so what does it mean for that
partition to be epsilon regular here
it's a second definition epsilon regular
partition so we say that a partition and
generally out to no partitions by curly
letters such as that P so the partition
well divide a vertex set into a bunch of
subsets so we say that that partition is
epsilon regular if the following is true
if I sum over all pairs of irregular or
pairs of vertex sets that are not
epsilon regular so over VI VJ not
epsilon regular and sum over the product
of their sizes then what I would like is
for the sum to be at most epsilon times
the number of pairs of vertices in G in
other words a small fraction of pairs of
vertices not necessarily edges such as
pairs of vertices lie between pairs of
vertex parts that are not epsilon
regular
and so for instance if you do not have
Epsilon if all of your parents are
Epsilon regular then the partition is
Epsilon regular but I do allow a small
number of blemishes and that will be
necessary
just to clarify a subtle point here here
I do allow in the summation I equals to
J although in practice it doesn't really
matter you'll see that it's not really
going to come up as an issue and one of
the reasons that it's not going to come
up as an issue is usually when we apply
this lemma we're going to have a lot of
parts in fact we can make sure that
there's a minimum number of parts and if
all the parts are none of the parts are
too big then having I equals to J
contribute very little to that sum
anyway in particular if all the set
sizes in this partition are roughly the
same so if they're all roughly one over
k fraction of the entire vertex set then
that statement up there being epsilon
regular partition up to changing this
epsilon is basically the same as saying
that fewer than epsilon fraction of the
pair's
VI VJ r naught epsilon regular and here
if K is large enough I can even let you
make I and J different it's not going to
affect things after small changes in
Epsilon so when it comes to so for
people who are seeing similarities
regularity
dilemma for the first time I think that
maybe all of you most of you I don't
want you to focus on the precise
statements so much as the spirit of the
lemma because if you get to nitty-gritty
with oh you know it's that same as that
epsilon you get very confused very
quickly so I want you focus on the
spirit of this this lemma meow I will
state everything precisely but the idea
is that most pairs are not epsilon
regular and don't worry too much about
if you're allowed to take I equals a J
or not so now we're ready to state
separatist regularity lemma and it says
that for every epsilon there exists some
constant M depending only on epsilon
such that every graph has an epsilon
regular partition into at most M parts
you give me the epsilon for example 1%
and there exists some constant such that
every graph has a 1% regular partition
into a bounded number of parts in
particular and this is very important
make sure you understand this part that
the number of parts does not depend on
the size of the graph
now it's true that for some grass maybe
you do need very many parts but the
number of parts does not get
substantially bigger
what does not exceed this pound even if
you look at graphs that have unbounded
size or so it is really a universal
theorem in the sense that it's
independent of the size of the graph any
questions about the statement of this
theorem yes that's right okay so the
question is why did I say that G is a
large dense graph and that's a great
question and it's because if G had a sub
linear number of edges then I claim that
all if you take if you look at the
definition of epsilon regular pair and
your epsilon is a constant and if your
edge densities are sub linear then all
of these guys they are little o of 1
they go to 0 so trivially you will
satisfy the epsilon regular condition so
if your graph is sparse sparse in a
sense of having sub quadratic number of
edges then you trivially obtained
epsilon regularity and so the theorem is
still true it's just not meaningful it's
just not useful but there are settings
we're having sparse graphs and we'll
come back to this later in the course
it's important to explore what happens
to sparse graphs
yes M is independent of G and depends
only on Epsilon okay question is what
happens when M is very large but they're
not enough vertices in the graph
well if your M is a million and your
graph only has a thousand vertices where
you can do is have every vertex be its
own part every vertex is on part a
singleton partition and you can check
that that partition satisfies the
properties every pair is a single edge
and this epsilon regular okay so my
understanding what you're asking is in
the definition up there the sum is we
put the pair in the sum of this epsilon
regular and otherwise don't put it is
there some gradual way to put some
measure of irregularity into that sum
and there are versions of regularity
lemma that do that but they're all in
spirit
morley the same as that one there
so in formal definition what does random
like me this is the formal definition of
when random like means so actually later
on in the course one of the chapters
this will explore what pseudo random
graphs are so pseudo random graph in
some sense means graph that are not
random but in behave in some sense like
random so random like generally just
means that in some aspect in some
property it looks like a random object
and this is one way that something can
look like random so a random graph has
this property but random graphs also
have many other properties that are not
being exhibited in this definition but
this is one way that graph can look like
random so that's a great question and
we'll come back to that topic later in
the course all these are great questions
right so some where it is regular till
about the first time you see it it can
look somewhat scary but I want you to
try to understand it more conceptually
so please do ask questions okay before
diving into the proof I want to make a
few more remarks about a statement it is
possible to okay so we will prove this
version of the regularity lemma but as I
mentioned it's the spirit of the
regularity lemma that I care more about
and there and it's a very robust
statement you can add on extra
decorations that somehow it doesn't
change the spirit and the proof will be
more or less the same before various
applications will be slightly more
useful so in particular it is possible
to make be partitioned equitable
and equitable partitions sometimes is
also called an ugly partition meaning
that it has such that all the a is all
the VIS have sizes differing by a most
one so basically all the parts have the
same size up to a most one because of
the visibility so let me state a version
of regularity lemma for equitable
partitions for every epsilon M local M
not there exists a Big M such that every
graph has an epsilon regular equitable
partition of the vertex set into K parts
where K is at least little m so I can
guarantee a minimum number of parts and
at most some bounded number again this
bound may depend on your inputs epsilon
and M not M not but it does not depend
on the graph itself and you see the
slightly stronger conclusion and for
many applications is more convenient to
use this formulation and I'll comment on
how you might modify the proof of that
the world should see today into while
where you can guarantee equitability
right and you see that for this M little
m not too small
for example if it's somewhat larger than
one over epsilon when you look at the
definition of epsilon regular partition
it suffices to check that a most epsilon
K square epsilon fraction of the pairs
VI be J epsilon regular / I different
from J again up to changing epsilon
let's say by a factor of two so there
all these all of these definitions are
basically the same up to a small changes
in the parameters
[Applause]
next time we'll see how to apply the
regularity lemma and we will apply it in
in the first form but you see the second
form guarantees you a somewhat stronger
conclusion and sometimes more convenient
to use so for example on the homework
problems if you wish to use a second
form then please go ahead so just to
make your life somewhat easier but it
essentially captures all the spirit of
similarities regularity lemma any
questions so far I want to explain the
idea of the proof of the regularity
lemma and this is very important
technique in this area called the energy
increment argument here's the idea we
start with some partition so for example
the trivial partition and by that I mean
you only have one part all the vertices
are in one part you're not doing
anything to the vertex set this one
gigantic part or if you're looking at
some other variant you can easily modify
the proof so for example you can also
look at an arbitrary partition into
little m not parts if you wish to have
that as your starting point so all I'm
saying that this proof is fairly robust
and we're going to do some iterations so
as long as your partition is not epsilon
regular
we will do something to the partition to
move forward and what we will do is look
at each pair of parts in your partition
that's not epsilon regular well if
they're not epsilon regular then I can
find a pair of subsets which ought to
know by the ace that witnesses this non
regularity so that witness is the
irregularity and we start with some
partition so now let us refine the
partition into a partition even even
more parts by simultaneously refine the
partition using all of these AI J's that
we found in the step above so you start
with some partition if it is not regular
I can chop up the various parts in some
way so I start with some partition over
here and what we're going to do is well
let's say between these two it's not
epsilon regular so I can find some pairs
of vertex sets that exhibits the
irregularity I chop it up and I can keep
further chopping up the rest of the
parts if these two parts are not epsilon
regular then I chop it up like that and
I can keep on doing it and origin only
have three parts now I have twelve parts
and this is a refine partition I know I
repeat until I am done right I am done
when I obtain a partition that is
epsilon regular now the basic question
when it comes to the strategy is are you
ever going to be done when are you going
to be done and if this process goes on
forever or goes on for a very long time
then you might have a lot of parts but
we want to guarantee that there's a
bounded number of parts so what we will
show is that we're to show that you have
a small number of parts in other words
why does this process even stop in
particular we want it to stop after a
small number of steps after a bounded
number of steps and to do this we will
define some notion called an energy of a
partition and this energy will increase
was the first of all the energy is some
quantity that we will define that lies
between 0 and 1 is some real number line
between 0 & 1 and each step the energy
goes up by some specific quantity
therefore because the energy cannot
increase pass 1 this iteration stops
after a bounded number of steps and once
it's done we end up with a epsilon
regular partition so that's the basic
strategy and what I want to show you is
how to execute that strategy any
questions so far
yes
so if I understand correctly you were
worried about between different pairs
you might have interactions so you are
seeing the proof but I think this is
actually a very important and very
somewhat subtle point is that I do not
refined at each step I find a pair of
witnessing sets I find all of these
winnings witnessing sets all at the same
time and I refined everything all at
once that is okay because this step
doesn't care if you have to witnessing
sets that overlap that is okay I will
see the proof yes
okay question is do we find just one
pair winning since witnessing sets even
though there could be more and the
answer is yes we just need to find one
there could be lots if it's not reps
alone regular it might be very not
Epsilon regular and in fact being a
witnessing set it's a fairly robust
notion if you just take out the small
number of vertices it's still witnesses
witnessing set any more questions okay
so let's take a quick break and then
we'll see the proof let's get started
with the proof of summarized regularity
lemma and to do the proof I will want to
develop this notion of energy which you
saw in the proof sketch so what do I
mean by energy well first if I let me
define some quantities if I have two
vertex
subsets U and W let me define this
quantity Q which is basically the edge
density squared but I normalize it
somewhat according to how big U and W
are I'm going to use the letter n to
denote the number of vertices in G so
this is some Q and for partitions if I
have a pair of partitions p u of U into
three parts and the partition PW of W
into L parts
I set this Q of PU and P W to be the
quantity where I sum over basically all
pairs one part from you one part from W
of this Q between UI and W J so this is
the density squared and I'm taking some
kind of weighted average of the squared
density so here it's a weighted average
if you prefer to think about a special
case where this partition is an equal
partition then it is really the average
of the squared densities it's a mean
square density and finally for a
partition P of the vertex set of G into
M parts we define the skew of this
partition P to be Q of P with itself
according to the previous definition or
in other words I do this double sum i
from 1 to M J from 1 to M Q of VI and
this is the quantity that I will call
the energy
of the partition it is a mean squared
density some weighted mean of the edge
densities between pairs of parts in the
partition you may ask why is it called
an energy so you might see from this
formula here it's a some kind of mean
square density so it's some kind of a
average of squares so in particular it's
some kind of an l2 quantity and there's
a general phenomenon in mathematics
I think borrowed from physical
intuitions that you can pretty much call
anything that's an l2 quantity in energy
and so that's I think where the name
comes from so this is an important
object for our proof and let's see how
to execute the strategy the energy
increment argument outlined on the board
over there so we want to show that you
can refine a partition that is not
epsilon regular in such a way that the
energy goes up and to do that let me
state a few lemmas regarding the energy
of a partition on the refinement
[Applause]
and the point of the next several lamas
is that the energy never decreases under
refinement and sometimes increases if
your graph is not apps if your partition
is not epsilon regular okay so the first
lemma is that if you look at the energy
between a pair of partitions it is never
less than the energy between the two
vertex sets so for instance if you unw
like that and partition them into pu and
PW and I measure the energy just
basically the squared density between U
and V versus summing up the individual
square densities after the partition the
left side is always at least the squared
as the right side so this is really a
claim it's a fairly simple clean about
convexity but let me set it up in a way
that will help some of the later proofs
so let me define a random variable Z in
the following way so here's a process
that we'll use to define this random
variable I will select X little X to be
a vertex uniformly chosen from you from
the left vertex set and I will select a
vertex Y uniformly chosen from Dublin
and so X&Y they fall into some part in
the partition so suppose you I is the
part where X I falls and WI is the set
in the partition where Y falls right so
U is a member of this partition w is a
member of the other partition W then I
define my random variable Z to be the
edge density between UI and W j WJ so
that's the definition pick X randomly
pick y randomly suppose X falls in you I
suppose Y falls in you J then Z is the
extensity between these two parts so Z
is some random variable so let's look at
properties of this random variable first
what is this expectation it's a discrete
random variable and you can easily
compute all of these quantities by just
summing up according to how Z is
generated so I look over all I and J
what's the probability that X falls on
UI it is the size of UI as a fraction of
you what's the probability that Y falls
in WJ it's the size of WJ as a fraction
of the size of W and then Z is this
quantity here so this is what I find to
be the expectation of Z but you see the
density multiplied by the product of the
vertex set sizes that's just the number
of edges between u and W and you sum
over all the I J's
that which is simply the edge density
between U and W so that's the
expectation of the Z variable on the
other hand what's the second moment in
other words what's the expectation of
the square of Z again we do the same
computation first part is the same the
second part now becomes a d square and
well look at what how we define energy
this quantity here is basically the
energy q between the partition you and
the partition of W except there say
there's normalization that's not quite
the same as the one we used before so we
all just put in that normalization all
right so now you compare the expectation
of Z versus the expectation of Z squared
and we know by convexity that the
expectation of Z squared is that least
as large as the expectation of Z that
quantity squared but if you plug in what
values you get for these two guys you
derive the inequality claimed in lemma 1
you have to cancel some normalization
factors but that's easy to do so that's
the first lemma the second one now
alright so the first one is just about a
pair of parts and then if I partition
each part what happens to the energy
between this pair and the second one is
a
direct corollary of the first one says
that if you have a second partition P
Prime that refines P then the energy of
the second partition the refinement is
never less than the energy of the first
partition and it is a direct consequence
of the first lemma because we simply
apply this lemma to every pair of parts
in P between every pair of parts the
energy can never go down so overall the
energy does not go down and finally so
so far we just said that the partitions
can never make the energy go down but in
order to do this proof we need to show
that the energy sometimes goes up and
that's the point of a third lemma so the
third lemma is tells us that you can get
an energy boost so this is the red ball
an energy boost if you are feeling
irregular
so if you w is not epsilon regular and
this epsilon regularity is witnessed by
you one in u and w one in W then I claim
that the energy obtained by chopping u
into u one and it's complement against W
one against the complement of W 1 and W
so here I again U and W I find a
witnessing set for their irregularity
and now I partition left and right
according to chop each part into two so
this energy between this partition into
two on both sides is bigger than the
original energy plus something where we
can gain and there's something where we
can gain turns out to be at least
epsilon raised to the power four times
size of you size of W divided by and
squared
[Applause]
let me prove it let's define Z the same
as in the previous proof I say the proof
of lemma one in remin one we just use
the fact that the l2 norm of Z the
expectation of the square is at least
square of the expectation but actually
their difference as a nick let's call
the variance the variance of Z is the
difference between these two quantities
know that it's always non-negative so if
you look at how we derived the
expectation of Z and expectation of Z
squared you immediately see that this
variance we can write as up to a
normalizing factor the difference
between this energy on one hand and the
energy of between U and W namely the
mean squared of the normalization on the
other hand the different way to
calculate the variance is that it is
equal to the expectation of the
deviation from the mean squared okay so
let's think about the deviation from the
mean I'm choosing a random vector in on
the left you and another random is a
random point random vertex on the left
and at random that point on the right in
the event that they both lie in the sets
that witness the irregularity
so in the event where X falls here and y
falls here which occurs with this
probability see that this quantity here
is equal to the density between U 1 and
W 1 minus the density and this
expectation of Z is just the density
between U and W so interpreting this
expectation for what happens when X
falls in new one and Y falls in W 1
ignoring all the other events because
the quality is always non-negative
everywhere but now from the definition
of epsilon regularity or rather the
witnessing of epsilon irregularity you
see that this u 1 is at least an epsilon
fraction of u w1 is at least an epsilon
fraction of W and this final quantity
here is at least epsilon inside so at
least epsilon squared so here we're
using all the different components of
the definition of epsilon regular yes
okay so you're asking what happens if we
divide with more witnessing says so hold
on to that talk so right now I'm just
showing what happens if you have what
witnessing set any more questions okay
so here we have epsilon to the fort and
if you're putting the normalisation
comparing these two interpretations you
find the inequality claimed by the lemma
all right so now we are ready to show
the key part of this iteration showing
that this iteration
I'll show you precisely how this
iteration works and show that you always
get an energy boost in the overall
partition I'll call the next one than
the forum and it says that if your
partition P the vertex set of G into K
parts if this partition is not epsilon
regular then there exists a refinement
we'll call Q where every part V sub I is
partitioned further into at most 2 to
the K parts
and such that the partition of to so
this energy of the new partition Q
increases substantially from the
previous partition P and will show that
you can increase by at least epsilon to
the fifth power some constant in epsilon
I so if we look at the strategy up there
if you can do this every step then that
means that a number of iterations is
bounded by 1 over epsilon to the fifth
power all right so to prove this lemma
here we will use the three lemmas up
there and put them together so for all
the pairs IJ such that P sub I V sub J
naught epsilon regular okay so as
outlined in the proof in the outline up
there we will find this a superscript IJ
in V I and a superscript j I in VJ that
witness the irregularity so do this
simultaneously for all pairs by command
J where VI VJ is not epsilon regular now
what we're going to define Q as is the
common refinement so take all of just as
indicating that picture up there
simultaneously take all of these A's and
use them to refine P
so starting with peak starting with a
partition you have simultaneously cut
everything up using all of these
witnessing sets remember you only have
witnessing pairs for pairs that are not
epsilon regular if they're epsilon
regular you don't worry about them all
right one of the claims in the lemma now
okay so this is this is the Q that will
end up with sure that this Q has that
property so one of the claims in the
lemma is that every VI is partitioned
into at most 2 to the K parts alright so
I hope that part is clear because how
are we doing the refinement we're taking
VI is divided into parts using these a I
J's one J coming from each pair that is
irregular with VI so I'm cutting up VI
using a most K says I'm coming from each
of the other possible may be fewer than
K that's fine by the most K sets is used
to cut up each v I know you have at most
2 to the K parts once you cut everything
up
all right the tricky part is to show
that you get an energy boost so okay so
let's do this how do we show that you
get an energy boost we're going to put
the top three lemons together first so
we want to analyze the energy of Q so
let's write it out so the energy of Q is
the sum over this energy of individual
partitions of the VIS
and by this piece of VI P sub BJ I mean
the partition of BJ given by Q so what
happens after you cut up VI so that's
what I mean by P sub BJ or rather I
should call it Q sub VI q ceviche okay
by lemma two
we find that okay so let me separate
them into two cases the first case sums
over IJ such that VI and J is epsilon
regular and by lemma 1 so here we're
using 1 we find that this quantity here
cannot be less than a q of VI VJ so take
those 2 parts before and after the
refinement by Q the energy cannot go
down so I don't worry too much about
pairs that are epsilon regular but now
let me look at pairs that are not
epsilon regular so what we will do now
yes even though so let's look at that
picture up there
so let's focus on the what I drew in red
so let's focus say between 1 & 2 so so
suppose a shaded part there's the
witnessing sets the witnessing says got
cut up further by other witnessing sets
but I don't have to worry about them
because lemma 2 and lemma one really
tells me that I can do an inequality
where I go down to just comparing the
energy between this partition of two
parts there's single witnessing set and
it's complement versus what happens in D
in its partner so in other words over
here the Q of this pair I am saying that
it is no less than if I just look at
what happens if you only cut up these
two sets using the red lines
all right let's go on applying lemma
three the energy boost lemma the first
part stays the same so this first part
stays in the second part now because I'm
looking at witnessing sets for
irregularity I get this extra boost so
so this goes back to one of the
questions asked earlier
we're in lemma 3 I don't have to now
worry about what happens if you have
further cuts because I only need to
worry about the case where I only have a
single cut between the epsilon irregular
pairs so putting it together we see that
the previous line is at least if you sum
over accuse of all the pair's plus this
extra epsilon to the fourth term for all
pairs that are not epsilon regular
I'm applying not monotonicity of energy
for the pipes part for pairs that are
epsilon regular and energy boost for
pairs that are not epsilon regular and
for the latter type I obtain this boost
now remember what's the definition of an
epsilon regular partition unfortunately
it's no longer on the board but it says
that this sum over here if it is epsilon
regular partition then it is at most
Epsilon
so if it is not epsilon regular we can
lower bound it and that's indeed the
first term here is by definition Q of
the partition P and the second sum by
the definition of epsilon regular is at
least epsilon to the power 5 so here
we're using the definition of epsilon
regular partition namely that a large
fraction at least an epsilon fraction
basically of pairs of vertex sets are
not epsilon regular but in this weighted
sense and that finishes the proof of
lemma for up there any questions so far
all right so now we are ready to finish
everything off and prove similarities
regularity lemma
[Applause]
Hiep so let's prove somebody's
regularity lemma let's start with the
trivial partition meaning just one large
part and we are going to repeatedly
apply lemma for whenever the partition
at hand is not regular so whenever the
current partition is not epsilon regular
alright so let's look at its energy the
energy of this partition so this is a
weighted mean of the H density squared
so it always lies between 0 and 1 so
just from the definition of energy on
the other hand the lemma tells us that
dilemma for tells us that the energy
increases by at least epsilon to the
fifth power at each iteration
so this process cannot continue forever
so must stop after at most epsilon to
the minus fifth power number of steps
and when we stop we must result in an
epsilon regular partition because
otherwise you're going to continue
applying the lemma and push it even
further that's it okay so that proofs
similarities graph regularity lemma
question ok let's talk about bounds
right so let's talk about how many parts
so how many parts does this proof
produce also we can figure it out right
so we have some number of steps each
step increases the number of parts by
something but so if P has K parts
so then lemma for refines P into at most
how many parts yeah so K times 2 to the
K okay and I have many iterations of
this guy so some of you are already
laughing because it's going to be a very
large number in fact because it's going
to be so large it makes my calculation
slightly more convenient that really
doesn't change the answer so much if I
just bound K to the 2 to the K by 2 to
the 2 to the K so the final number of
parts yes this function iterated on
itself epsilon to the minus 5 times so
it's a power of 2 of height
and most to to the epsilon to the five
it's a finite number okay so it depends
only on epsilon and not on the size of
your graph and this is the most
important thing it does not depend on
the size of your graph it is quite large
in fact even for reasonable values of
epsilon like one percent or even ten
percent this number is astronomically
large and you may ask is it really
necessary because you know we did this
proof and you know came out fairly
elegantly I would say it how the proof
was set up and you arrived at this
finite bound but maybe there's a better
proof maybe you can work harder and
obtain some more better bounds so you
can ask is it possible without the truth
is really somehow much smaller and the
answer turns out to be no so there's a
theorem by kim gaurs which says that
okay so there exists some constant the
precise statement again it's not so
important but basically what I just said
you cannot improve the spout given by
this proof so for every epsilon let's
say small enough there exists a graph
whose epsilon regular partition requires
how many parts so the number of parts at
least this power of twos of height some
epsilon to the minus C
so really it's a tower of Exponential's
of size essentially polynomial in one
over epsilon so maybe you can squeeze
the five to something let's actually we
don't even know that's the case but
certainly you cannot do substantially
better than what the proof gives so
similarities regularity lemma is an
extremely powerful tool and we'll see
applications that are basically very
difficult to prove and from some of
these applications we don't really know
other proofs except using somewhere this
regularity lemma but on the other hand
it gives terrible quantitative bounce so
there is a lot of interest in
combinatorics where once you see a proof
that requires similarities regularity
lemma that is first proved using this
technique to ask can it be used using
some other technique in fact similarly
himself has worked a lot in that
direction trying to get rid of the users
of his level okay any questions
okay great questions how can we modify
for equipartition alright so let's talk
about that so I it's a fantastic
question so look at this proof and see
what can we do if we really want all the
parts to have roughly the same size
let's say differing by almost one
so how to make Epsilon
any guesses any attempts on what we can
do
I mean basically is going to follow this
proof as I said the spirit of
similarities regularity lemma is what
I've shown you but the details and
executions may vary somewhat depending
on a specific purpose you have in mind
so you're saying we're going to add
something or to massage the partition to
make it episode vertices to the smaller
parts of the partition now when are you
going to do that so you want to do this
at every stage of the process okay I
like that idea so here's what we're
going to do so we still run the same
process so we're going to have this P
which is the current partition current
partition and as before we initially
have it as either the trivial partition
if you like or M arbitrary I clue the
ballpark's start with something where
you don't really care about anything
except for the size and you run
basically the same proof where if your P
is not epsilon regular then okay so what
do what we've done before to basically
exactly the same thing we refine P using
pairs wouldn't it sing
irregularity okay so same as the proof
that we just did and now we need to do
something a little bit more to obtain a
credibility and what we will do is right
after so each step in the iteration
right after we do this refinement after
we cut up our graph maybe some of the
parts are really tiny let's massage the
partition somewhat to make them
equitable and to make our life a little
bit easier we can refine the partition
somewhat further to chop it up into
somewhat smaller resolution and this
part you can really do it either
arbitrarily or randomly it doesn't some
ways may be slightly easier to execute
but it doesn't really matter how you do
it it's fairly robust you refine it
further and well basically I want to
make it equitable sometimes you can just
do that by refining but maybe if you
have some really small parts then you
might need to move some vertices around
so I'll call that rebalancing okay so
move and merge some vertices but only a
very small number of vertices to make
equitable okay so you run this group
until you find that your partition is
absolutely cooler than you were done
whenever you run this group because
we're doing the second step your
partition is always going to be
equitable but we now need to control the
energy again to limit the number of
steps and the point here is that the
first part still see exactly the same as
before by the energy
goes up by at least epsilon to the minus
five but the second part the energy
might go down because we're no longer
refining just refine it because we're
doing some rebalancing but you can do in
such a way that the amount of
rebalancing that you do is really small
you're not actually changing the energy
by so much so I'll just hand wave here
and say that we can do this in such a
way where the energy my go down but only
a little bit so you're only changing a
very small number of vertices very small
fraction of vertices so if you change
only an epsilon fraction of vertices you
don't expect the energy which is
something that comes out of summing
pairs of vertex parts to change by all
that much so putting these two together
you see that the energy still goes up by
let's say at least half of epsilon over
to the fifth power and so then the rest
of the proof runs the same as before you
finish in some bounded number of steps
and you result in an equitable partition
that's absolute so I don't want to
belabor the details here there are some
things to check but it's I think fairly
routine well it's more of an exercise in
technical details but but the thing that
actually is somewhat important is
there's a wrong way to do this and I
just want to point out that what's the
wrong way to do this is that you apply
regularity lemma and you think well now
I have something that's epsilon regular
then I massage it to try to make it
equitable at the end so I don't look
into the proof I just look at a
statement of some radius regularity
lemma I guess something that's epsilon
regular I said I'm just going to divide
things up a little bit further that
doesn't work because the property of
being epsilon regular is
actually not preserved on the refinement
so look at the definition you have
something that's epsilon regular you
refine the partition a my fail to be
epsilon regular so you really have to
take into the proof to get equitability
okay so just to repeat a wrong way to
try to get a credibility is to apply
regularity lemma and at the end try to
massage it to get to get equitable that
doesn't work all right next time I will
show you how to apply some readies
regularity lemma